(beeping)
(speaking foreign language)
- Welcome back to your essay writing
and presentation skills class.
Now we are in a way on our road
to discuss our presentation skills.
In the previous lecture, as you can see on the slide,
we have discussed the three stage process
of how to develop and how to create one good presentation.
We also discussed it, how to be clear
about the purpose of your presentation.
We also discussed some of the techniques
that how you can make your presentation good
by rehearsing it well, by maintaining the eye contact
and be comfortable.
We also discussed that you are supposed to follow
the PowerPoint creation tips and tricks
to make one presentation look very good.
Then you are going to provide the appropriate amount
of information in the time allocated.
So this time management is very important
when you talk about the presenting something
in front of your audience or on the stage.
Then handling the question answers confidently
is another thing that we have discussed,
that how you can handle your question answers
while you want to make your presentations look
and sound beautiful for your audience.
To move on and to begin with,
today we are to start our lecture number three
in which we are going to discuss some of the tips
of your presentation skills.
So we are to discuss some of the tips
that can make your presentation look good
and people will love it once you deliver
your presentation in front of them.
So giving presentation is not a big deal.
Now I told you in the previous lecture
that you are supposed to keep in mind
that you were not born a presenter.
Now that you are in a process of learning
about how to make one good presentation
and how to deliver one good presentation,
you can become one good presenter.
So don't worry about that and don't panic.
Your fears should be gone because you are to relax
because I am here to support you
and I'm here to guide you and I'm here to share with you
that how to deliver your presentations effectively.
As you would have seen that and you would have learned
from the passage of time, from the very first lecture
that I kept telling you that this communication
has something to do with your communication.
This presentation has something to do
with your communication.
Now this communication of yours revolves
around the language that you use
and it also revolves around your nonverbal
and your verbal pose, the two poles of verbal
and nonverbal communication which you are supposed
to keep in mind when you make your presentation.
Now your verbal communication has something to do
with your voice, your words, your language,
the choice of language that you are using
and your nonverbal has something to do
with your hand movements, with your facial expressions,
with your eye contact and so on and so forth.
So you are going to make sure that you are going to stick
to or follow all those things that come under verbal
and nonverbal communication that we are going to discuss
in our upcoming lectures in detail also as to make sure
that you are not going to digress from any point
that can decorate the attention of your audience.
So to begin with our lecture number 23,
there are some tips for your presentation skills
that can make you a very good presenter.
So to begin with, let's begin with the introduction
that what exactly presentation skills are
and how you are supposed to deliver them
in front of the audience.
So first of all, let's see how you define presentation skills.
Either one or two day format participants will secure
the scale base to speak before groups of any size
with poise and confidence they might never have thought
possible.
So maybe in your life or maybe in your routine life,
you are supposed to face a group of people
to speak confidently in front of them to utter
or to convey your point of view to them.
Now in this situation, since you become the only focal person
or you become the solo speaker of the whole situation,
you become the good presenter
or you become one of the presenters of the situation
in other words.
Audience comprehension source because presenter
learns to deliver content with technique
that both inspire and entertain.
So you are supposed to remember that you are supposed
to stick to and you are supposed to, you know,
tingle to your audience attention
and your audience comprehension that they are
comprehending whatever you are saying
because you are to convey your point of view
to your audience and you are to entertain them also.
So in other words, you can say that this presentation
skill has something to do.
This presentation should be fun for your audience
as well as it should be fun for you.
So that was the introduction of how do you define
the presentation skills.
Now moving on to the next slide.
Now let's talk about the agenda of today's lecture
that what are the things that we are going to focus on
while you prepare yourself for a good presentation.
Now today we are going to focus on a few things
that you can very well see on the slide.
The number one is the delivery of presentation.
The second one is the presentation content
that we will discuss at what kind of a content
you are supposed to insert in your presentation
as to make sure that the audience is comprehending it well.
The presentation design that what design you should
or what type of design you should adopt
for your presentation, then how you can handle the question
and answers and finally the proper use of humor
in your presentation.
Along with that, we will also discuss in detail.
I will also show you a video clip that will help you summarize
everything that we are going to discuss today.
So to begin with, let's first of all
start with the delivery of presentation
that how you are supposed to deliver the presentation.
Before moving on to that, we discuss the whole agenda
of today's lecture.
Let me discuss the learning objectives
that what you will be able to achieve after we are to do
whether after we are done with this today's lecture number 23.
Now you will be able to know how to feel confident to stand
and deliver before any size group.
Now first thing that you will be confident to do after learning
about this presentation is that you will
be able to stand in front of that group of people confidently
to whom you are trying to deliver the presentation to.
Then use your eye contact gestures and body language
for the maximum effect.
So if you see if the voice is coming
and you cannot see the person, maybe the message is not
being delivered to you properly.
But the combination of your nonverbal and your verbal discussion
or your communication leads to the very active message that
is being understood and that is being
comprehended by your audience.
Then develop and organize a presentation for any audience
and for any event.
So you would be able to develop one presentation
and then organize one presentation
to be delivered in front of your group of people in front
of you are going to do not deliver that too.
Then design visuals to enhance both presenters message
and performance.
So as I said yesterday as well in our previous lecture
that how these audio visual aids or visual aids
can be very, very beneficial for your audience
to see that how they can benefit from them.
So these visuals should be used, all the visuals,
all the things that you are inserting in your presentation
should be relevant and up to the date.
As I'll show you some of the videos, one video today
by the end of the lecture and we will
see that how the whole information is being
listed down in that one video.
Then deliver visual information in a way
that keeps the audience in sync.
Handle tough questions, master memorization techniques.
Now you would be able to master these memorization techniques
that you are not going to forget anything
in front of the audience.
And then we said that you are going to able to handle
the tough questions whatsoever.
It is once you have this topic command
and once you know that what you are talking about,
you will be able to answer or satisfy
the queries of your audience.
Then use humor effectively.
Now humor is one element that should
be there when you are talking about presentation skills.
Because if your presentation is flat,
it will look dull and boring.
If you are not interested, it gives an impression
that you are not yourself interested in presenting
the subject that you are presenting.
And as it will not be a fun for you,
it will not be a fun for your audience.
So make it interesting by inserting in humor in it.
So in today's lecture, we will learn
that how to insert and how to pour in humor
in your presentation skills.
Now the first thing that we are going to discuss
is the delivery of presentation.
We are going to focus on that how to deliver your presentation
in front of the audience.
So to move on with, let's see that what
is the step number one for delivery
that you are supposed to do for to deliver
your active presentations.
Speaking before a group, once you are supposed to,
once you are asked to present the number one fear that comes
in your mind is this is the human fear that you are kind of
hesitant to convey your ideas in front of the group
or maybe the number of people who
are sitting right in front of you.
You see when you, for the first time when you go in the class
or the first week when you go in the class,
you are kind of hesitant in talking to the new people.
When you go in the market and you are being,
you do not talk to the strangers and you do not talk to them.
Sometimes it happens that you are hesitant in conveying
your idea publicly.
So this fear of talking to the larger number of group
is always there with you when we talk about the presentation
skills.
So this is the most common human fear.
So you are not to worry about.
You can feel nervous and there can be uneasiness
that fear creates.
So you can sometimes, you can feel nausea,
you can feel thargent, you can feel exhausted.
Now there is kind of uneasiness in your behavior
once you plan for speaking out in front of a group.
So for the delivery of the presentation,
this is the most common human fear that
is there in front of everyone.
Whatever age you reach or whatever age limit you are in,
maybe you are in your late 50s or maybe you are in your early
20s, this stage fear is always there.
Only kids is that kind of a breed who
are not afraid of speaking in front of a group of people.
But yet there are differences in the kids.
Also there are a few kids who feel hesitant to speak
in front of the audience.
Yet there are others who never feel shy to deliver their thoughts
in front of the audience or in front of the group of people
who are sitting there and they are listening to you.
Now imagine that you are the center of attention
and everyone is looking at you that when
are you going to begin speaking about something
that you have to tell them.
Now see, what would happen to you?
Of course, there will be a lot of nervousness.
Maybe your hands are shaky and your cheeks are blushing
and you are feeling nausea or maybe you
are fearing more than death that you will die before you
utter any word.
So there is kind of uneasiness before you actually
plan to deliver your presentation in front of the audience.
Although speaking to a group is reported to be number one
human fear, the truth is a bit more nuanced.
Participants only believe they fear public speaking
because their most common behaviors when in the spotlight
produce exactly the same physiological responses
as when they are generally facing a life threatening event.
Now see, let's try to note down the words which
are of our center of attention while we try
to elaborate this paragraph for you.
Now see, most of the participants or most of the people
whom the ones who have been asked that why do you fear so much
when you are supposed to deliver a presentation,
they mostly say that they fear once they are spotlighted.
So your physical conditions that your legs
are shaking, your hands are shaking, your cheeks
are blushing, and your ears, your ears, they are warm.
And maybe you're here, they are woody and sticky.
They automatically become because you
are fearing so much that you don't know
that what to do in that situation.
Now this physical responses are related
to your mental responses.
That is there because they are sending those messages
to your body that you are nervous,
you are feeling uneasy, and you are feeling this fear is there.
You will learn to take command of your audience
by challenging your nervous energy
into a dynamic presentation scales
if you stick to all the rules that I'm going to share with you.
So do you want to become one dynamic presenter?
Yes, you want to.
I'm sure that you want to, and you
want to secure good marks in your exams
because presentation is that chunk that carries some marks,
the proper 15% weightage in your essay writing and presentation
skills class exam.
So make sure that you are going to learn everything
that I'm going to tell you in the presentation.
Maybe the topics are being assigned to you by your teacher
or maybe the topics that you are going
to present on are being selected by yourself.
Whatever the case is, you are going to make sure
that you are not going to feel this fear.
Why?
Because presentation is not something
that you were born with.
Now, you are in a process of learning
that how to deliver one good presentation.
If you know all the tapes that I'm
going to share with you while you try to make
one good presentation, and if you know
that how to deliver that in front of the audience,
definitely you would be able to produce one good presentation
and you would become the loveliest presenter for all.
So let's move on to the next slide
and see that what you are supposed to do while you actually
are in a stage or on a stage to deliver
your presentation in front of the audience.
When a presenter feels confident,
a confident audience feels more comfortable.
Now, if the presenter that's up to the presenter,
that how he portrays himself in front of the audiences
who the group of people who is sitting right in front of him
to comprehend each and everything that he's talking about.
So to, in other words, you can say that, for example,
if I am the presenter and I am presenting right
in front of you, and I start saying that today,
my topic of presentation is, I forgot, sorry.
Let me look back at the slide and tell you
that what is my topic.
So I look so nervous and so uneasy.
And if there is something touching in my throat,
let's say, if I start my presentation like this,
Aslamalikum, everyone, my name is Elanoshid
and I am going to present on so-and-so topic, see.
These kind of things can be, you know,
they are not going to appeal to your audience
because they are producing such kind of impressions
or they are giving such vibes to your audience
that you are not comfortable
and you are not confident about what you are going to present.
So to begin with, once you start actually
delivering your presentation, you should sound confident.
Remember, in the previous lecture,
I told you that you were supposed to take a deep breath.
Take a deep breath before you actually start
or saying any word.
Now, see that I have taken one breath
and I am coming with this flood of words that is coming
and that was in my brain and I was,
I am, you know, communicating them to you
through a proper language.
Now, you see, this language is very important
when you actually plan on delivering the presentation
in front of the audience.
Now, how?
Because the collection of the words that you are using
to deliver your presentation in front of the audience
becomes one of the very interesting parts
because mostly there are the cases being seen
where people while sitting in a very business-like environment
and the presenter, he starts speaking in Urdu.
Now, Urdu, although is our own language
but the official communication,
the business communication being done
is usually in the English skills.
So to begin with, even if you are not finding any word
out in the English language to be translated in Urdu,
try to see that you use this bilingualism technique
in your presentation skills as to make sure
that you are not going to full fledger rely on only one language
that is Urdu because this is the modern life
and English is our official communication language.
So we are going to make sure that you achieve
that level of proficiency in English
while you are standing on a stage and while you actually
want to deliver your presentation.
Now, you must be wondering that how to speak.
Now, all of us are not alike and we cannot speak good English.
So the thumb rule is that what you are going to do
if you are being asked to speak English
that you prepare well.
That doesn't have anything to do with cramming.
Try to use those simple words that you know the meaning of
and try to stick to them, try to elaborate those points
being written in the bullets on your slide
in your own words which are easy and which are understandable
and which you are not hesitant to make
the grammatical structure for.
So coming back to our delivery, if you feel confident,
if you are confidently standing on the stage,
the audience will be comfortable and that is going to give you
room for providing the information
and this is going to become one conducive environment
for persuasion.
Now, this environment or this atmosphere thing
is really important when we talk about the delivery.
So the first thing that you are doing
is to feel confident.
You would feel confident about your topic because you are
already so much prepared.
You are so much prepared about your topic
that you feel so much confident and you
want to deliver it in front of the audience
with full devotion and with full confidence.
In other words, whenever the brain senses a potential threat
in the case of one person speaking to a group,
it's the one against many scenario.
The body responds with the same chemical preparations
to deal with the threat as it does when one experiences a blow
out at 70 MPH.
Now, relating back to the previous slide in which we were
saying that how your bodily functions start reacting
once you are feeling this fear.
So you are not going to feel this fear because this
is a human behavior.
That's in your behavior that your body,
it automatically starts giving responses
to what is going to happen to you.
Because the brain or mind, it sends signals to our body
that how to react.
When you are thirsty, you pick up a glass
and you pour in a water and you drink.
Because your mind is telling you or the mind is sending you
the signals that you are to do so.
So your bodily functions, they move accordingly
because this is all your human behavior.
So you are not to worry about that.
The first thumb rule that I have told you
that you should feel confident.
You would only feel confident about your topic
once you have attained that command on your topic
as well as you know that how to handle
your audiences sitting right in front of you.
Now, by simply changing a few of these wrongly taught
behaviors, participants discover they can completely
change their body response.
With very little practice, the fear is first listened
and then it is gone.
So you are here to practice the presentation skills.
Now with this little practice, first of all,
this fear will be listened, it will be listened,
and then it will be gone forever.
So there is no self hypnosis, no fuzzy or neuro reprogramming
or no reliance on the positive thinking.
There is only one thing that you are supposed to do
that is practice while you actually
want to become a good presenter.
The process that takes participants from poor to average
to expert is one of the simply, that simply involves
modifying three things that they have done
since this first stand up book report in grade school.
Now, remember when you were a small kid,
your teacher, she called you out and she said,
there come a stand here right in front of the whole class
and then deliver and then read out this chapter
or read out this poem for everyone.
And you did that without any fear.
Now what was that fear?
That fear was related to your behavior
because somehow you have learned that presenting
in front of the audience is something
that you should fear of.
Now this humanly behavior should be avoided
to make sure that you, from the poor, you learn from the poor
presenter, being a poor presenter, you become an average
and then you become an expert.
So we are in a process of making you an expert
for the presentation.
So stick to whatever I'm saying and I'm trying to tell you.
So your delivery counts most once you come on the stage
and once you try to deliver your argument in front
of the audience.
Remember, your delivery is your number one fear
because you don't know how to start your presentation.
I've told you that you should begin your presentation
confidently because your opening matters more
than what you are to deliver in your presentation.
Now let's talk about the presentation content,
that how you can make your presentation content
look interesting and good for the comprehension
for your audience.
Now let's try to read that out.
You contain the bottom line is that the listeners
don't care what you do.
They care about what you can do for them.
Now whatever you are doing and whatever,
how much fearful you are, they only care.
Your audience will only care that what you can do for them
because they are more interested in.
They are not interested in, for example,
you are presenting any idea in front of them.
They are not interested in that you have done so.
They are more interested in that why you have done that for them.
So try to answer their theory that what is there for them
and why should they be interested in listening to you
for such a longer period of time.
Participants learn to talk in terms of results, feelings,
benefits, outcomes, and ideas.
So they would look for the results
that they can comprehend after the presentation.
They will also, the presentation should appeal to their feelings
also that they should feel something about your presentation.
What are the benefits for them?
What are the outcomes for them?
So this is the best idea before you actually
start your presentation.
As I did today, that you are supposed
to tell them the learning outcomes
before you actually start your presentation
because they will get to know that why should they
sit for such a long period and listen to you.
Because you have told them the learning outcomes,
which will be achieved while you present on your topic.
They learned to imagine audience members with signs
on their foreheads that read, so what?
What's in it for me?
So you see, if you are standing on the stage
and if you start looking at different audiences who
are sitting right in front of you,
and if you start looking on their faces,
their faces will question you.
Now, this nonverbal behavior is something
that almost kills you when you are standing on the stage.
Sometimes, if the audience makes such impressions
that they are not understanding anything,
and if they give you this impression through your facial
expression, that they are not interested in what
you are talking about, you feel very down
and you don't feel motivated to present your topic.
Why? Because sometimes, you do not grab
or you do not gather their attention
or you do not bring their attention towards your topic.
Now, how to do that?
You should make that interesting,
and you should tell them in the beginning
about what they are going to learn
about through your presentation.
Thus, time is thus allotted to the content relevancy
and organization of the presentation.
So, you are supposed to focus on for that,
you are supposed to focus on the content,
the relevant material, and the organization
of your presentation, so that you can deliver your presentation
in front of the audience fully and completely,
and they don't make faces at you,
that they are not learning anything.
So, your presentation will tell them through its content
that what is there for your audience clearly.
Now, the number three thing that we are going to discuss today
is the presentation design.
Now, see that we also examine how a computer-based presentation
have become more the norm than a novelty,
audiences are often overwhelmed
with poorly developed productions.
So, you see, these computer-based
or these power point presentations
are becoming more and more popular every day
because you have margin of designing more and more
in your power point presentation
instead of presenting them in the poor ways.
Maybe if you are being given the presentation
and you are presenting it through one chart
or maybe you are writing on the board.
Now, presentation skills are somewhat different
from your lecture method or the way you deliver your speeches.
Presentation is something that you are supposed
to deliver in front of the audience
with the help of any medium that is presentable.
Now, as a part of presentation design module,
participants realize the important of proper delivery
of visual information.
Now, if you are designing your presentation,
make sure that the visuals are there
once you try to communicate or once you try to deliver
one point to your audience.
Understand how the brain processes visual input.
Now, you should understand before you make your participants,
understand before you make your audience,
understand that how these visuals are giving you one thought
or how these visuals are related or relevant
to whatever you are saying.
Comprehend simplifying how less is more.
So, sometimes the presentation design helps your reader
understand that how less is more.
So, how in a very short hour by just simply showing them
one visual, you can tell them about so many things.
Gain control of audience attention
through layout and timing.
So, you are going to make sure that whenever
you are going to design your presentation,
you are going to lay it out in front of the audience
in such a way that is going to save your time
as well as theirs.
Discover 10 techniques to guarantee
that presented and audience are involved.
So, now, try to brainstorm and try to see
that what can be those possible 10 techniques
which can be kept in mind to see that you
and your audience are involved in the presentation.
So, think twice before you actually start
designing your presentation.
I will share with you some of the techniques
that how you can make your presentation style
or presentation fonts, presentation outlay
or layout look good in front of the audience
and how you can insert in the best visuals
for your in your presentations.
Now, handling question answers is another thing
that is supposed to be kept in mind
while you plan for making down one good presentation.
Now, talking about it, sometimes the prepared presentation
is only a prelude to real program,
the question and answer session.
Now, this question and answer session
is more important because once you are done with,
once you have allocated 20 minutes for your presentation
and five minutes for the question answers
or maybe the 10 minutes for question answers,
you must make sure that your question answer session
is going to give a prelude to the real program
of your presentation.
So, depending on the forms needed up to one quarter
of classroom time can be scheduled
for the question answer processes.
So, as I said that if you are giving 75% of the time
for your delivery of presentation,
try to save 25% of the time for your question answer session.
To enhance the relevancy of this module,
participants prepare and trade questions
that they would actually encounter
in their real business environment.
So, you are supposed to look at your presentation
from every possible point of view
from where the questions can come in the minds of reader
and they can focus on them, they can deliver one
or they can ask for questions from you.
Now, moving on to the next slide,
through questions and answers,
the participants learn how to ask questions
and properly address the questioner.
Now, you will learn that how to answer these questions
or how to handle these questions
while you are trying to satisfy the QED of your audience.
How do you listen for the real question?
Now, that you are standing in such a situation
where there are a lot of participants focusing on you
and they are looking forward to what you have to deliver
to them, you are going to make sure
that you try to handle those questions
which look relevant to you
and you are going to handle them smartly.
If there is any irrelevant question
that is not related to your topic,
try to ignore, don't try to tell them
that don't try to answer them,
just simply tell them on the spot that this is,
I don't feel it related to what I have been delivering.
Please rephrase your question
or maybe I'm wrong to listen to you
or something like that, but do not shun them
or do not try to ban or try to, you know,
slap them because sometimes the audience,
they are looking forward to the answers from you.
How do you need to realize negative questions?
So, this is how if there is any negative question
being asked from you related to your topic.
Now, see the questions whatsoever
would be coming to you, won't be related to you
and if there is any question that is related to you,
don't try to answer it, just simply tell them
that I would appreciate that if you stick to the topic
that I've presented, just say it in a very polite way
so that they get to know that you are not interested
in telling them about yourself.
There are some presenters who feel it very good
once people ask them different questions
about their personality and their grooming,
but there are other speakers who are not comfortable.
So, don't try to, you know,
some of them try to neutralize the negative questions
and try to avoid them on the spot.
How to deliver and format the answer to the entire group?
Now, one more thing that you are supposed to keep in mind
while answering the questions of your audience,
keep in mind that if there is one person
who has asked you the question,
you are not going to only answer him,
you are going to satisfy and you are going to address
to the whole group which is sitting right in front of you.
To do so, you are supposed to keep eye contact
with everyone and your major eye contact will be
with a person who has asked you the question.
Now, how to tie the answer back to the content
of the original presentation?
Now, for every question that your audience is asking you,
you are going to bring them back to the presentation.
Now, remember I told you the ground rule
that all the, to make sure that all your questions
are related to your presentation,
just try to make sure that you tell them the ground rules
in the beginning and in those ground rules,
you are going to tell them that if they have any questions
or if they have any queries related to the presentation,
they can ask you by the end of the presentation for to do so.
They are supposed to keep the track of the page numbers
or the slight numbers which are written there
in your presentation.
So, to do so, you are supposed to insert the page numbers
well in your presentation as to see that how you can bring them
back to the actual topic of your presentation
or your original presentation.
How to deal with the unexpected contingencies?
Now, there can be some unexpected flaws
or unexpected situations where people might flood up you
with a lot of questions or people,
there can be other situations where people will not
ask you a single question.
So, you are going to see and you are going to mentally
be prepared that if there are going to be a lot of questions,
so how much, in how much time I will satisfy their queries.
So, you would have to see that if there are 10 questions
coming in 10 minutes, so how much time you have to give
to every answer.
So, you have to be very, very precise, very, very concise,
yet you are supposed to be very clear
while you try to appeal to the comprehension
of your audience's knowledge.
So, that was all about your question, answer sessions.
I hope that you have learned that how to answer,
a question answers for how to answer the questions
of your audiences because you are supposed
to stick to only the presentation content
that is there in front of your audience
because if you are not going to do so,
your audience might drag or might take
your attention somewhere else.
So, try to avoid the personal questions,
try to make your presentation look more formal
and behave more formal in front of the audience
so that they cannot talk to you
or they cannot challenge your capabilities
and confidence in front of everyone
by asking you irrelevant questions
or by making fun of you.
So, you are not going to let anyone make fun of you
because since you have all the command on your topic,
you are going to handle your topic well
and then you are going to deliver your presentation
more effectively.
Now, the last thing that we are going to discuss
before we move on to the summary
and before I show you one good presentation
of one good presentation model
that is going to summarize what we have discussed today.
There is another thing, the use of humor in your presentation.
Now, if your presentation is dull, flat and boring,
your participant will not be interested in you.
If you look so dull and so tired
and if you are not inserting in any humor
in your presentation, your participants will not be involved
because they want to look at someone who looks interesting.
At the same time, he or she is presenting
something really interesting.
So, how you can use humor in your presentation?
There is an excess of advice
on using humor in presentations out there
and most if it is just plain wrong.
Improper use of humor can trip up
even the most seasoned presenters.
Now, you are going to make sure
that the proper kind of humor is there.
Now, if you start involving your, for example,
you tell them about any story
that is about your life,
that you feel is kind of humorous and funny
that can be shared with the audience,
but that is not related to your topic.
So, sometimes it can affect your presentation
and sometimes it can be of a very bad idea
about your presentation.
Instead, participants will come away knowing
that when and when not to use humor in the presentation.
So, you are going to see that when and when not to use
this humor thing in your presentation
because sometimes your audience
are not very much appealed
with how you use humor in your presentation.
So, your humor should be related to your presentation.
You should know if your audience
are getting dull and boring
and they are yawning sometimes
and they you feel that they are not active,
actively listening to you.
So, try to insert in some humor
so that or try to see that how you can grab their attention
towards the presentation again.
So, to do so, try to mingle up with the audiences
before actually you start your presentation,
try to learn their names and if you find people yawning
during the presentation or if you don't find people
listening to you or they are talking to each other,
you can directly call them from their name
and you can tell them that I would appreciate
if you listen to my debate first,
then we are going to have your debate to be listened later.
So, you can, you know,
sarcastically or ironically you are supposed to move
very with this good balance of Partism and Humor.
What type of humor to use and what to avoid?
So, you are going to see that what kind of a humor,
this should not be a childish kind of a humor
in your presentation during your delivery
because that is not going to appeal to the logic
or appeal to the sense of your audience.
How to use humor effectively even if you are not funny.
So, there are people who are very serious by nature
and even though those people they are supposed to,
you know, insert an important humor
in their presentations, once they are presenting
something in front of the audience
because sometimes humor is effective technique
for making your presentations look interesting
and even if you are not a very funny person,
you should sound, at least you should sound humorous
for your audiences.
So, bringing in or pouring in the right kind of a humor
in your presentation is more important
than anything else in the whole world.
Now, let's see that what methodology you should adopt
for your presentations.
Methodology follows the three terms,
self-realization, participation and process improvement.
Now, these are three things that you are supposed
to keep in mind which revolve around the methodology,
the overall methodology of your presentation,
self-realization, you should realize
that who you are and what you are presenting.
So, this self-realization is very important.
Sometimes you forget about yourself while presenting
and you so much focus on the topic
that sometimes you forget that you are presenting Y.
So, this Y is very important
like just to give you an example.
The managers of different companies
they go to other companies as the representative
of one company A.
For example, this is company A and this is company B.
Now, this manager of company A is going to company B
to present or to talk about or to make the employees
of company B get aware of the product
that they have recently launched.
Maybe that's a laptop.
Now, that member A or that manager A of company
or organization A once will go to the company B
will become the representative of company A.
Now, this is your role model
and this is your responsibility.
This is your realization.
This is your actual self-realization
that you are the representative of organization A
who is going to go to organization B to support that
or to launch that or to market that product
that is laptop for the employees of company B.
Now, this self-realization is very important.
You should not get into the foot or get into the shoes
of those people like let's say once you have reached company B
you start thinking that the product is your authority
and the product is all your property
and you are the owner.
No, you are the representative of the company
and you should keep on telling them this realistic fact
that you have come there on the behalf of your company.
So, this is how you can self-realize
and get why you are presenting on the stage.
Then participation, of course you are the active presenter,
you are presenting, your participation is there
but try to make sure that you involve
and you try to bring in the participation
of your audience also.
Try to ask them questions, try to invite their participation
while you try to make your presentation look more successful.
This is another method that can be used
for making your presentation look good.
Then process improvement, how you can improve
the process of your presentation
by making your audience think that your product
is more interesting than anyone else.
So, this is how you can introduce them well.
You can present them the content well
and in the end you can conclude your presentation well
so that you can have try to or you can solve their queries
if there are any.
So, that was the methodology.
Now, let's talk about each one of them in detail
and let's try to see that how these things are related.
Sessions begin with establishing a current competency
based on the client preference we include video tape.
As skills are learned, participants
expand their self-realization through peer review
in addition to coaching by instructors.
Now, that you have realized that why are you standing
or why are you delivering on the stage,
there is another thing that you are supposed to remember
is that you can actually see or you can actually realize
yourself if you listen to the peer review sometimes.
For example, if there are friends of yours
sitting in the presentation or if you are delivering
the presentation in front of your teacher
and your instructor, you can ask them for the feedback later
that how successful you were in presenting your topic
because this is going to help you actually realize
that what point you stand on and how much you have to work
more to make your presentation look different and interesting.
Your participation includes demonstrations
by instructors of the required behavior.
The majority of presentation time is given
to the participants actually performing the techniques
required for proper presenting.
So, your participation as well as during the training process,
your participation is very important
and while you are actually practicing it,
that is also very important because you want
to deliver the best presentations.
The skills to becoming a persuasive and effective presenter
are broken down into different steps
that can be easily absorbed at each step.
So, you are going to listen to each and every process step
that is there to become one good presenter
and to achieve that level of moving from poor
to normal average and then to the expert presenter.
Now, moving on to the next slide,
how the participants will benefit.
Now, how the participants will benefit
from everything that we have discussed in today's lecture.
Let's first recap the delivery thing
that we have discussed during our lecture.
The first thing in learning the skills
to present ideas before a group in a persuasive fashion,
participants both gain confidence in themselves
and better forward to the organization's mission.
Now, before you actually start to persuade the attention
of your reader by feeling confident,
you can pour in the confidence in yourself also.
Participants gain self-realization
through overcoming the most common human fear.
Now, you realize that what is your reality?
You are not a meek man.
You are one confident person who was sent to this world
to do something and you should realize
that what you can do other than just eating
and sleeping and reading.
Employees become better all around communicators.
So, everyone or anyone including employees and students
and anyone who is interested in learning something
through your confidence of delivery,
you can become one good communicator
and one good presenter.
Now, about the content gaining the skill to develop
presentations that inspire and persuade transforms
into a better business writing, organizational skills.
Now, let's see that what kind of a content
you make to learn while you actually practice it,
report generation and knowledge transfer
outside the presentation process.
So, how you are going to best present the content
that you know and you are going to deliver it
to your audience.
Now, everything is not written on the slides
to be presented in front of the audience.
There are a few things which count more
than how, which are there in your brain
and you don't write them on the slides yet,
you have the margin of speaking out
in front of the audience to tell them
that how much command do you have about that topic.
Now, about the presentation visuals, participants gain
in the standing of how simplifying ideas
can increase the comprehension.
So, your participants, if you are going
to insert the proper visuals in your presentation,
your participants will get to learn
that how simplifying ideas can increase comprehension,
how new concepts need to be introduced
in the elementary form and how these precepts apply
to all aspects of their job.
So, this is how you can target to or you can value
to your audience by inserting
in the right kind of visuals.
Now, question and answer, participants learn
the art of listening and through listening
in appreciation of diversity of learning styles.
Now, your participants, once you are going
to tell them the ground rule that they are supposed
to listen to you carefully for the question answers
to be taken by the end of the lecture,
what you can do is that your participants
will listen this art of listening.
Cooperation and understanding between scope worker
is enhanced as participation discover other points of view.
Participants learn how to develop positive responses
to potentially negative situations.
Now, you would understand that how to develop
the positive response to the potentially negative situations
in a very beautiful way.
So, you have learned that how to handle the question answers,
the negative questions being asked
and how you are going to handle them properly
in your presentation.
So, that brings us to the end of today's lecture.
As you see the example, I will tell you
that how to stick to all the tips
that we have discussed in today's presentation.
Now, let's see this example.
And after that, let's say goodbye to each other.
Now, let's see that.
Tips for making an effective PowerPoint presentation.
Designing PowerPoint slides.
Tips for making your PowerPoint more effective
as well as attractive.
Keep text simple and consistent.
That is urgent.
Find creative ways to reduce details.
Put some of the details in handouts, hidden slides
or links to websites or create a written document.
Decide how many slides to include.
A loose guideline is right in front of you.
Depending on how much details on slides
and how much discussion on each slide.
Decide what to include.
You won't be able to include everything
so be selective.
Juice colors deliberately.
Colors have an emotional impact.
So, choose colors that create the desired tone.
Other than photos don't use too many.
Juice design elements allow white space
don't overdo fancy effects.
Know your equipment.
Practice well enough so that there is no distraction.
(upbeat music)
Prepare to deliver.
Practice out loud.
In front of a small audience.
Practice not looking at your slides much.
Reduce text.
If there is too much text,
you know you are going to read out.
Use graphical layouts.
Crafts and diagrams helps easy illustrations.
Avoid bullets on every slide.
Too linear, too wordy, too boring, too predictable.
Promotes reading the slides and promotes reading ahead.
Make a poor handout or document.
Avoid clip art in your slides.
That's the best idea.
Find or take photos instead of inserting
in the clip art techniques.
Here is to your success in making your presentation
effective and attractive.
So that was all for today.
I hope you have enjoyed today's lecture
and you have learned that how to make one good presentation
and how to make one good edited presentation.
And I hope that you are going to follow all the tips
that we have discussed during our whole lesson.
Now that you have learned that how to use humor,
how to use the content,
how to handle the question answers
and how to actually deliver your presentation.
We are in a process of making good presentations.
I hope if you stick to all these points,
like if you know that how to actually deliver
your presentation with the confidence,
if you know that what kind of content
and you are supposed to insert in your presentation
for which I have also shown you one video.
And if you know that how to make use of humor
in your presentation,
and if you know that how to handle the question
answers sessions you will be in a better position
to make one good presentation.
With that, I wish you a very good luck
for following these steps that we have discussed today.
I'll see you in the next class.
Till then take good care of yourself, a la hafes.
[BLANK_AUDIO]